e aí galera 16 no planalto com você e
ela te dá notícia pra vocês ontem o gol
o próprio senhor google notificou os dez
canais no youtube que mais cresceram 1
ano de 2014 está apertado em primeiro
exatamente porta dos fundos mas eu tenho
orgulho de dizer pra vocês para dizer
para todos os meus bichos soltos que eu
estou entre os dez canais que mais
cresceram no youtube 2014 tudo isso
graças a quem a mim e brincadeira gente
graças a vocês porque eu também leva em
consideração os comentários e leva em
consideração o número de inscritos e
leva em consideração o número de likes
que você recebe nos vídeos o número de
compartilhamento e tudo isso quem faz
por mim
são vocês que eu fico muito orgulhoso
fico orgulhoso de mim também de vocês
pra gente está colocando o meu canal
entre os dez maiores do brasil tá ligado
então nordeste eo nordeste entre 10 e
nordeste entre o experiente no meio de
tudo nordeste receita no meio de tudo
sentenciada no lugar dele vai nos sushis
do xingu e nordeste inter vai à pizzaria
pizza nordeste a venda da mecha ensaio
nordeste vai para são paulo volta
puxando efe porta a porta é o gay
nordeste eo nordeste está no meio dos
dez maiores canais do youtube do brasil
em 2014 e 2015 com certeza será um dos
três maiores porque na china
se você gostou desta notícia quer ver as
fontes confiáveis está aqui embaixo na
descrição do vídeo fail do g1 abril a
nós sobre que vem falar que vamos lá
recentemente fiz um show de stand up
comedy lá em manaus no amazonas a e do
vozão em timon
aonde o pior
a gente ficou meio de uma final onde a
neve foi aumentando eo lê o nome eu
tenho que confessar para vocês que foi
um dos melhores shows eu já fiz na minha
vida
primeiro porque não fiz ao eu fiz 44
shows em um dia 12 horas ou quatro horas
o outros seis horas que o território na
frente do outro e foi meu deus foi porão
todos top foi top até jornal union se
liga
roque beleza que quando eu cheguei
manaus foi direto ao hotel chega em nota
é para o meu quarto me banha eu pensei
no meu deus para eu avisar o povo de
manaus e outro em manaus eu tenho que
tirar um foto aqui e e postar 11 vence
lá embaixo do hotel e na porta do hotel
tinha uma banquinha de venda de coisa
tem marcha tinha colocar a flecha eo
scola fez sido a escolha da região e
tinha uma lança a ser por vou tirar foto
com essa mãe quem fez a pose tirar foto
postei uma legenda manaus peixe
preparado embora nem por manaus a decat
de barros reconheceu os rios laço
conhecer um lugar muito [ __ ] conhecer o
trabalho de um carro que fazê-las
casinha pequenina assim foi o cinema no
teatro e show de humor voltei quando eu
voltei eu fui na foto os comentários da
foto a galera brigando obrigando obrigam
a que falta de respeito falar o que o
povo de manaus é tudo índio é que falta
de respeito dizendo que o povo de manada
é tudo indígena grande falta de respeito
com o povo de manaus manaus tem muita
civilização isso é um preconceito
comediantes em de merda começando a
carreira já faz piada de mau gosto
popular de manaus evento só que estava
comentando isso é a galera de fora o que
o povo de manaus fala não posso
de manaus e tenho muito orgulho da minha
cultura é uma coisa normal quem passa
por equipe e o povo de fora mantendo
paulo é preconceito é preconceito é
preconceito engraçado que o pessoal de
manada de lisboa que o pessoal de fora
diz que é preconceito sendo que eu
cheguei no hotel eu fui tirar uma foto
com uma coisa que já estava ali e não
foi o mato fabricavam lança para tirar
uma foto fazendo piadinha novo the city
e óleo com flash e um lança um colocar
um colar a gente um favor o preconceito
só acaba quando vocês para achar
preconceito em tudo se nem as pessoas
que lá tava achando ruim porque as
pessoas de fora vão se do rei por uma
coisa que tem nada a ver com ela só tem
aqui uma coisa é você quem vê
preconceito em tudo é a pessoa mais
preconceituosa que tem gente que você
não pode comer no bob's e foi o primeiro
bola só pára tentar com c como é que o
dólar não tem pra você como é que tal
não convide média por quanto tempo a
gente não pode ser assim eu fiz meu show
o show foi maravilhoso um dos melhores
shows da minha vida eu ganhei muito
presente entre os presentes viu que eu
ganhei um arco e flash eu ganhei um arco
e flecha então quer dizer que a minha
foto dizendo que lá é não só tem índio
não tinha foi está sendo preconceituosa
me dar um presente de si para ficar
pensando que lá só tem índio não vou
virar índio cards não é só o presente
carinhoso de um funk eu vou guardar com
todo o carinho do mundo do mundo que a
coisa que mais gosto na minha vida aos
presentes meus fãs me dão e lá na minha
casa no dia 2 é um quarto só por causa
de vocês é acho que sim e esse ano eu
fui pra mostrar pra vocês que vou
guardar com o maior carinho do mundo e
tem muitos casos disse que teve uma vez
que eu comentei a ter motivo tem um
shopping quando você qual é o que fez
uma ação publicitária dizendo assim e
todos vivemos juntos não sei que sem
medo de ser feliz ea e botou a foto de
dois homens se beijando e por mim tanto
faz pode dois anos beijando a todo mundo
tem o direito de fazer o que você quiser
é porque eu e minha namorada tem o
direito de passar fotos beijando e um
homem porque eu e minha namorada
e postar fotos beijando e dois anos não
pode postar fotos beijando acho que pode
tomar ó só que eu comentei só que eu
comentei que tinha achado errado um
shopping usar isso o shopping usar dois
homens se beijando a se promover à época
maria e se aproveitar da situação não eu
comentei olha eu acho ridículo shopping
usar isso pra querer se promover e
inclusive eu tenho vários amigos gays e
eu falo pra todo mundo que os amigos
gays são as pessoas mais alegres que
você pode andar na sua vida a pessoa
mais engraçada são muito engraçado você
pode contar sempre você precisar melhor
que é muito amigo meu que você tem
melhor que muita mulher que você tem
também eu acho que isso aí um cara
comentou assim você é o pior tipo de
homofóbico que existe porque não adianta
que você pode ser a pessoa mais pura do
mundo você tentasse a pessoa mais legal
que existe um mundo sem ter pra ninguém
sempre vai chegar alguém apostar pra
você e dizer que você é uma forma é
muito fácil a cabeça de preconceito você
gosta de andar de carro
eu gosto de andar de moto e se chama
darolt ficar falando não prefiro ficar
aqui na minha moto mesmo é pra você fala
assim o celpe o tipo de carro ao fogo
que tem agora para ver como eu não só
uma foto do beijo cá ele é tão joaquim
vai dizer sim mas não foi de língua não
adianta tentar dialogar e eu como sou a
pessoa que eu conheço a pessoa que sua
inspiração não sei para muitas pessoas o
médico faz na internet mas todas as
pessoas são o que sua inspiração então
penso que vocês gente não seja desse
jeito não fui procurado preconceito em
tudo desenvolvido que vocês feliz não
destaca que ninguém seja educado com sua
mãe com seu pai e respeito de pai e mãe
você para alongar seu dia na tela
especial não vale mais a não falar em
alta com os mais velhos sempre a pessoa
precisa de a grande família judia é isso
você tem que ser uma pessoa boa não a
pessoa que fica procurando o efeito não
tá se você está no facebook sem curtir
pra dar uma mãozinha pra mim que você
está aqui no youtube
pode acontecer de o santantônio amizades
abbey
eu só tinha visto antes de fiança não
desaparece tentam com cada lado nesse
vídeo achado no cunho preconceituoso e
joão pessoa e joana deve ficar
procurando por preconceito eu quero que
você comece aqui embaixo você já passou
a situação de alguém achar que você é
preconceituoso e se chama meu canal pra
frente virou você sabe né
obrigada a assistir se viu até aqui e é
nóis que em razão de engenharia como é
que um número que vou aqui na área
eu só vou lançar a publicação os nos
tira o lugar a ninguém caso ruby que os
r chute provou uma libra de cada livro e
gostei